es geht um ein geheimes staatsdokument
um Überwachung um die weltmachtpläne von
Präsident shinping und um einen hohen
Preis den G für ihren Mut bezahlen muss
wir haben die Frau getroffen die dafür
verurteilt wurde dieses Dokument an
ausländische Medien gegeben zu haben sie
erzählt uns ihre Geschichte und die hört
sich an wie ein
Krimi ich wollte meinen Sohn retten und
habe gesagt was sie von mir hören
wollten
[Musik]
ihr seht hier hinter mir das ist die
Skyline von Peking hier arbeite ich als
Korrespondentin für das ZDF das
Hauptquartier der Kommunistischen Partei
Chinas liegt mitten in Peking aber
Chinas Machtzentrum ist eine Blackbox
umso prisanter dass 2013 aus diesem
Machtzentrum ein geheimes Dokument an
die Öffentlichkeit kommt das Dokument
Nummer 9 und dass es gelegt wurde ist
ungewöhnlich denn normalerweise gelangt
nichts an die Öffentlichkeit was nicht
an die Öffentlichkeit gelangen soll
dafür sorgt der Kontrollapparat der
Kommunistischen Partei ich ma mal ein
Beispiel ich war im vergangenen Jahr
beim Parteitag der Kommunistischen
Partei der Parteitag bei dem Shin Ping
sich über die bisherige Begrenzung
hinweggesetzt hat und sich für eine
bisher eben nicht mögliche dritte
Amtszeit bestätigen ließ das war in der
großen Halle des Volkes ich habe euch
die mal mitgebracht die ist nämlich hier
auf diesem 100 Yen schin drauf und in
dieser Halle hier steht beim Parteitag
jede tetasse am genau dafür vorgesehenen
Platz selbst das Tee
einschenken das machen die synchron das
ist eine richtige Zeremonie die sogar
vorher geprobt wird während hier bei
diesem Parteitag seine Rede hielt war
der ganze Raum mit mehreren Taus
Delegierten muxsmäuschen still ich war
noch nie in so einem großen Raum mit so
vielen Leuten der so ruhig war das
einzige was zu hören war war das
kollektive Umblättern weil die
Delegierten die Rede im Manuskript
mitlasen diese Parteitage die sind eine
große Show alles ist vorher abgesprochen
nichts passiert dort aus Versehen alle
Posten sind schon vergeben und die
vielen vielen Delegierten die sind nur
dabei um die längst getroffenen
Entscheidungen abzunicken und um dieser
Machtdemonstration chiden Pings einen
pompösen Rahmen zu
verleihen umso spannender also dass
dieses Dokument 2013 an die
Öffentlichkeit kommt damals findet es
nicht sehr viel Beachtung vielleicht
weil uns da noch nicht klar war wie sehr
dieser neue Präsident China verändern
würde was steht denn jetzt also drin in
diesem Dokument Nummer 9 es ist wohl das
wichtigste Dokument um die Politik von
Chinas allmächtigen Führer chidinping
heute zu verstehen damit ihr die vielen
Seiten nicht lesen müsst haben wir das
für euch gemacht und ich greif mal drei
wichtige Punkte raus der erste ist diese
westlichen Werte die bezeichnet das
Dokument als Bedrohung für die
Kommunistische Partei und für das System
Chinas sie würden eine Bresche schlagen
für die ideologische Unterwanderung
Chinas der zweite Punkt deshalb soll die
Gefahr aus dem Westen laut Dokument
gebannt werden also
Kontrolle Kontrolle durch die Partei mit
Genosse Chi an der Spitze und drittens
taucht ein Bild auf das hii immer wieder
benutzt der Traum von der chinesischen
Wiedergeburt er will China zur Nummer
ein in der Welt machen militärisch
wirtschaftlich und
[Musik]
kulturellplan hat nicht nur China und
die ganzen globalen Beziehungen
verändert sondern auch das Leben von GÜ
sie wird verhaftet mit dem Vorwurf des
Dokument an ausländische Medien
geschickt zu
haben ich bek daskument nicht früh
zugeschickt ich glaubte zuerst gar nicht
dass es wirklich ein Dokument der Partei
sei jede Chinesin jeder Chinese der sich
mit ihr trifft muss mit Konsequenzen
rechnen sie selbst sowieso um alle
Beteiligten zu schützen haben wir sie an
einem Ort getroffen den man hier nicht
erkennen soll bei so einem Interview ist
immer bis zur letzten Minute nicht klar
ob es wirklich klappt oft werden
Interviewpartnerinnen und Partner oder
auch ihre Familien unter Druck gesetzt
das erste was wir bei so einem Interview
machen und das war für mich als ich hier
nach China kam total komisch am Anfang
wir sammeln alle Handys ein von allen
Beteiligten im Raum und bringen die in
einen anderen Raum um zu verhindern dass
irgendjemand mithört der nicht mithören
soll natürlich wird die Staatssicherheit
mich später besuchen das zdfteam hier in
Peking berichtet damals von ihrem
Prozess ich habe mal ins Archiv geschaut
und zeig euch einen Ausschnitt den wir
damals in den Abendnachrichten gesendet
haben angekommen vor dem Gericht drängen
Polizei und stadsicherheit schon zurück
drehen sei hier verboten behaupten sie
der chinesische Staat will keine
Berichterstattung über den Prozess gegen
eine der bekanntesten JournalistInnen
des Landes g sagt dass Sie das Dokument
nie verschickt habe doch schon lange vor
ihrem Prozess wird ein Geständnis von
ihr in den staatlich kontrollierten
Fernsehnachrichten
ausgestrahlt hat klar erklärt dass diese
Aussage erzwungen wurde weil sie unter
Druck gesetzt wurde dass auch ihr Sohn
verfolgt werden
könnte
ich wollte meinen Sohn retten und habe
gesagt was sie von mir hören wollten
hätte ich gewusst dass er draußen ist
hätte ich mein Geständnis sofort
wiederrufen nach einem Jahr
Untersuchungshaft wird sie zu 7 Jahren
Gefängnis verurteilt nach einigen
Monaten darf sie überraschend gehen
nicht nur güs Leben hat das Dokument
Nummer 9 bis heute verändert sondern das
aller Chinesinnen und
[Musik]
Chinesen
für Form von Andersartigkeit eine Gefahr
eine Gefahr für den Zusammenhalt des
Systems politische Gegner Kritiker oder
Anwälte hat er mundtot gemacht er schürt
Misstrauen gegen den Westen
Wirtschaftsprojekte z.B die neue
Seidenstraße nutzt er um seinen
politischen Einfluss in der Welt
auszuweiten er schmiedet neue globale
Allianzen will unabhängig werden vom
Westen und den USA denn der so die
standarderklärung der Propaganda die ich
hier in Peking jeden Tag höre der Westen
der will China unterdrücken und Schuld
an allem sind die USA ich habe mal
meinen Kollegen in den USA gefragt wie
das in seinem berichtsgebiet eigentlich
so ankommt also hier wird das natürlich
als völlig absurd angesehen 70% der
Amerikaner sehen China auch eigentlich
als eine Bedrohung und das kommt eben
nicht von ungefähr weil sie glauben dass
China wirtschaftlich militärisch und
politisch versucht gewissermaßen die
Weltherrschaft zu
[Musik]
übernehmen
der zweite Punkt in den 10 Jahren unter
Chi hat er als Staats und Parteichef das
chinesische System umgebaut
Kontrolle das ist sein höchstes Ziel und
die hat er komplett in seiner Hand
gebündelt ich war dabei als hi gemacht
hat was keiner seiner Vorgänger
geschafft hat er hat sich zum dritten
Mal als Generalsekretär der
Kommunistischen Partei und als Präsident
Chinas bestätigen lassen dafür hat er
die Verfassung geändert denn für seine
Vorgänger war nach zwei Amtszeiten
Schluss er kann nun bis an sein
Lebensende Nummer ein bleiben beim eben
schon erwähnten Parteitag im Herbst 2022
wurde Kies Vorgänger rutchen Tau
offensichtlich gegen seinen Willen und
vor den Augen aller Parteikader aus dem
Saal geführt wir kamen zu diesem Moment
gerade in den Saal und das war eine ganz
unangenehme Atmosphäre die Leute wussten
nicht was da passiert wussten nicht wie
sie sich verhalten sollen und für uns
das deprimierende bis heute wissen wir
immer noch nicht genau was damals
eigentlich los war solche Fälle die
gibt's immer immer wier erst vor ein
paar Wochen verschwand plötzlich Chinas
[Musik]
Außenminister der dritte Punkt die Rede
vom Traum der nationalen Wiedergeburt
auch dieses Ziel aus dem Dokument Nummer
9 verfolgt ch bis
2049 das ist das hunderste
Gründungsjubiläum der Volksrepublik will
er China zur wichtigsten Weltmacht
machen sein Rezept dazu Aufrüstung
Nationalismus und natürlich
Kontrolle wir werden alles dafür geben
dass unser Traum von einer großen und
starken Nation in Erfüllung geht China
versucht alles um militärisch die Nummer
eins zu sein im Grunde mindestens im
Indopazifik und vielleicht auch anderswo
sagen zu können wo es lang geht die
Handelswege zu kontrollieren und damit
auch in der Lage zu sein andere Länder
in unter Druck zu setzen rund um den
Erdball und deswegen sagen hier die
Experten aber auch die Politiker in den
USA ist China eine Bedrohung weil wenn
es in der Lage wäre sich durchzusetzen
dann K könnten überall rund um den
Erdball die autoritären Regime auf dem
Vormarsch sein und dann können wir sowas
wie die Karta der Vereinten Nationen
territoriale Integrität und Souveränität
Menschenrechte die universalen
Menschenrechte da können wir die
vergessen dann sind die nicht mehr das
Papierwert auf dem sie geschrieben sind
chiden Ping setzt also seinen Plan den
wir aus dem Dokument Nummer 9 kennen
ziemlich genau um wie hat er China damit
in den vergangenen 10 Jahren verändert
schon vor Chi erlebte China mit der
wirtschaftlichen Öffnung zum en ein
Wirtschaftswunder und ein enormes
Wachstum Millionen Chinesinnen und
Chinesen sind seit den 80ern aus der
Armut zu Wohlstand oder gar Reichtum
gekommen hi hat sich Armutsbekämpfung
auf die Fahnen geschrieben und das
Rechnen ihm viele hoch an das erleben
wir auch selbst z.B bei unseren
drehreisen auf dem Land da zeigen uns
die Menschen stolz dass sie jetzt z.B
einen Wasserhahn im Hof haben und nicht
mehr zum Brunnen müssen oder dass ein
großer Flachbild TV im Wohnzimmer hängt
oder dass ihre Kinder in der Stadt
arbeiten und dort gutes Geld ver
verdienen und diese Leute die bedanken
sich dafür bei ihrem
Präsidenten wenn es um die Rivalität mit
den USA geht dann ist chinen die
Hightech Metropole im Südosten Chinas
sowas wie der Wirklichkeit gewordene
chinesische Traum ich war selbst auch
schon paar mal dort man kann sich dort
anschauen wie die Zukunft aussehen wird
shenjen ist total jung hip super schnell
die Stadt steht für neueste Technologie
für Innovation und Startups für
selbstfahrende Taxen und für Babel der
per Drohne geliefert wird auch das ist
China unter chiden Ping das ist der Deal
den Chi und die Kommunistische Partei
mit ihrem Volk haben also wir sorgen
dafür dass es euch immer besser geht
dafür haltet ihr euch aus der Politik
raus und lasst uns
[Musik]
machen doch genau dieser Deal der ist in
Gefahr das ist möglicherweise der
gefährlichste Punkt seit 1989 denn wir
haben eine Jugendgeneration hier die für
sich keine positiven Zukunftsaussichten
sieht und wenn wir etwas aus der
chinesischen Geschichte gelernt haben
ist das große Umbrüche oder zumindest
große Proteste immer dann passieren wenn
die Jugend in den Städten unzufrieden
ist und keine Zukunft für sich sieht das
liegt daran dass Chinas Wirtschaft sich
nach dem Ende der coronapolitik nicht so
schnell erholt wie erwartet von den
jungen hat jede und jeder fünfte keinen
Job und das sind nur die offiziellen
Zahlen inoffiziell sind es
wahrscheinlich noch viel mehr aber schon
die offiziellen Zahlen die sind so
schlecht dass die Statistikbehörde die
Quote für die 16 bis 24-Jährigen nun
nicht mehr veröffentlicht das ist eine
klassische Lösung der Staatsführung
keine Zahl kein Problem das es den
jungen Leuten nicht gut geht das hat
unser Team hier z.B in Peking vor dem
lamaatempel gesehen das ist so eine
Sehenswürdigkeit wo auch viele Touristen
hingehen und sich den Tempel angucken
und das warar ein Tag an dem es ganz
schön geregnet hat und trotzdem standen
viele Leute dort
Schlange wir beten dass wir gute
Praktikumsplätze bekommen und gute
Jobmöglichkeiten haben
werden ich hoffe dass ich einen Job
finde ich suche schon seit einer Weile
die Jobsituation ist echt angespannt
viele haben während der coronazeit ihren
Job verloren und die Kommunistische
Partei die hat viel Vertrauen verspielt
ich bin im Mai 2022 nach China
eingereist und da verfolgte China noch
streng seine Null covidptik damit war
das Land zu Beginn der Pandemie auch
ganz schon erfolgreich nutzte diesen
Vorsprung dann aber nicht vor allem in
Shanghai erzählen die die den
mehrmonatigen chaotischen Lockdown dort
mitgemacht haben wie sehr das Vertrauen
in die Führung erschüttert
[Musik]
ist das Dokument Nummer 9 ist 10 Jahre
alt 10 Jahre und das waren hiiesjahre
Schritt für Schritt setzt er um was er
damals angekündigt hat und regiert aus
dieser Blackbox im Herzen Pekings für
Menschen wie GÜ ist hiies chinesischer
Traum eher ein Albtraum ein Albtraum und
unter einem Präsidenten der an der Macht
bleiben kann solange er lebt was
passiert wenn wir das Interview mit GÜ
ausstrahlen es ist dieses Gefühl der
Ohnmacht diese Verantwortung für
MitarbeiterInnen oder Interviewpartner
die ich bisher in meiner Arbeit als
Journalistin in dieser Weise nicht
kannte zum Schluss habe ich sie gefragt
was sie sich für ihr Land
wünscht民 ich hoffe sehr dass das
chinesische Volk ein für allemal die
Menschenrechte erhält natürlich kann
dies nur durch ein freies und
demokratisches System erreicht werden
was glaubt ihr und was kennt ihr von
China habt ihr vielleicht sogar einen
persönlichen Bezug und welche Fragen
interessieren euch denn für das nächste
Video global politics schreibt uns und
wenn ihr noch mehr sehen wollt nehmen
wir euch hier mit nach Taiwan ich habe
dort junge Leute getroffen die das
Gefühl haben sich auf einen Krieg mit
China vorbereiten zu müssen den Sie
nicht wollen und wenn Ihr hier klickt
dann bekommt ihr ein Film über das
Verhältnis zwischen China und Russland
und wie sich das durch Russlands Angriff
auf die Ukraine verändert hat